released in november 1996 space jam
became an instant classic sports movie
not to mention a millennial cultural
touchstone it took a long time to get a
sequel off the ground but it's finally
on its way
hitting theaters and hbo max in july
2021
here's everything you need to know about
space jam and new legacy
the first space jam employed a fairly
standard if bizarre high-stakes science
fiction plot line
with the addition of basketball after
the classic looney tunes characters were
kidnapped by alien creatures called the
nerd
lux to the attractions at a theme park
in space bug's buddy recruited michael
jordan and challenged the villains who
stole the powers of nba stars to a
basketball game
if they lose they'd remain captives what
about we raise the stakes a little bit
the plot of a new legacy suggests it's
not a direct sequel but an updating and
reimagining of the first movie's story
and themes
this time the movie centers on the
present day's most dominant basketball
player lebron james
as he and his son get trapped in the
digital world by an evil artificial
intelligence program
in order to win freedom for himself and
dom james has to train
lead and play alongside all those goofy
looney tune cartoon characters
including bugs bunny lola bunny and
daffy duck
standing in their way impossibly tough
basketball superhero monsters and robots
based on real life nba stars
including james own team mates and
friends
the original space champ not only
definitely mixed live-action with
animation
but it also combined a cast of acting
neophyte athletes with veteran comic
performers
on the jock side space jam starred
michael jordan of course with
appearances from charles barkley and
larry bird
while bill murray and wayne knight aka
newman from seinfeld
represented the funny side space jam 2
will take a similar approach
star lebron james is also producing the
movie via his company spring hill
entertainment
in march 2019 suniqua martin greene of
star trek discovery and the walking dead
joined the cast set to play james's wife
oscar and emmy nominated actor don
cheadle will play the villain
a computer algorithm named algae rhythm
the younger cast of the film includes
harper lee alexander as james daughter
and cedric joe as the basketball star's
youngest son whose kidnapping feels the
plot of the movie
many longtime looney tunes voice actors
worked on space jam a new legacy but
there are also fresh voices
comedian gabriel iglesias is set to
portray speedy gonzales
while emmy-winning euphoria star zendaya
will play lola bunny
if space gemini legacy is anything like
the first space jam from 1996
it's going to feature a lot of
interstellar basketball the previous
film included some of jordan's
contemporaries
and the new legacy looks to follow a
similar approach with big stars of the
present day
some nba and wnba stars will portray
themselves as the goon squad
super powered hybrid monsters competing
against james
okay let's analyze the competition
anthony davis plays a birdman named the
brow
while damien lillard is kronos a golden
robot with clock parts
wnba talents diana taurasi and neka
aguma k will voice the serpentine white
mamba
and spider-like arachnika respectively
and clay thompson is wet fire
who can harness the powers of water and
flame a new legacy will include other
basketball world cameos as well
including brief appearances from players
kyrie irving chris paul and draymond
green
as well as inside the nba host ernie
johnson embodying a play-by-play
commentator
also perhaps to bridge the two space jam
films one more basketball playing
superstar might be in the new legacy
cast
don cheadle told access hollywood in may
michael jordan is in the movie
but not in the way you'd expect warner
brothers on lebron james's production
company spring hill entertainment
announced in september 2018 that space
jam 2 was actually
officially happening as the film is set
to feature a number
of basketball stars it couldn't shoot
much during the nba season
which means it took a while for space
jammer new legacy to arrive
in february 2019 spring hill tweeted out
some concept art for the movie
james alongside bugs and lola bunny as
well as a release date
july 16th 2021 that date may have
numerical significance
per sports reporter rob perez july is
the 7th month of the year
and if that 7 is added to the 16 it
makes 23.
that's the longtime jersey number worn
by both space jump stars michael jordan
and lebron james unlike dozens of other
major films the release date for a new
legacy was unaffected by coronavirus
related theater closures
but the method in which it will reach
the public will be different in december
2020
warner brothers announced that while it
would screen its big 2021 movies in
theaters
it would simultaneously release them on
the streaming service hbo max
for a period of 30 days that mid-july
date will also fall drawing or
immediately following the 2021
nba playoffs making for a fortuitous
promotional opportunity
as of may 2016 fast and furious 6
director justin lin
looked to be the front runner to helm
space jump 2 but that didn't quite
happen
in september 2018 the hollywood reporter
broke the news that the sequel would be
ryan coogler's first movie
after his directorial blockbuster
triumph of black panther but as a
producer
handling directorial duties terence
nance an indie darling and experimental
filmmaker animator responsible for the
movie the oversimplification of her
beauty
and the hbo series random acts of
flyness a few months later nance was out
and malcolm d
lim was in according to the rap the
director of the hit comedies night
school and girls trip
worked from a script with multiple
credited screenwriters not counting the
four men who'd written the original
space jam upon which several of the new
film's characters are based
among those who took a pass at the
script creed 2 screenwriter joel taylor
keenan coogler ryan coogler's brother
and writer of the upcoming creed 3
and terence nance space jammer new
legacy is all about mixtures
it's partially animated and partially
live action it features lebron james
playing basketball against animal human
hybrids and it incorporates familiar
characters from multiple franchises
warner brothers produced and distributed
space jam a new legacy
and that company falls under a large
corporate umbrella that also includes
its premier day streaming home of hbo
max and the looney tunes characters
prominently featured in the movie
warner's also had writers and producers
insert a lot of its intellectual
property
into the space jam sequel creating a
vast interconnected cinematic universe
the plot of the film legitimately
explains it all james and his son become
stuck in the server verse
a cloud storage space where every movie
character and tv show under warner
brothers control resides
this allows james to commune with the
tornado from the 1939 film version of
the wizard of oz
the violent street criminals from a
clockwork orange characters from hbo's
game of thrones
yogi bear the iron giant and many more
including pennywise the clown
space ghost and one of the thundercats
well that happened
why while those are surprising additions
space jam a new legacy will not include
a character from the original space jam
the famously lascivious skunk pepe le
pew it's originally scripted scene in
which he reports that the object of his
affection took out a restraining order
has been
cut over concerns that it was too
problematic
the original space jam was a
multi-format smash
not only did the filmer 90.4 million
dollars at the north american box office
but the accompanying soundtrack album
sold 6 million copies
thanks to top 10 singles from seal r
kelly and monica
lou legacy will also promote itself
musically with a soundtrack full of
major contemporary and breaking artists
set for release a week before the film
officially opens
hip-hop superstars lil baby 24k golden
chance the rapper lil uzi vert and
brockhampton
contributed songs as did the jonas
brothers soul singers john legend and
leon bridges
and hamilton and in the heights breakout
anthony ramos
the soundtrack also features about that
time a collaboration between white dave
pilo g-eazy and dame dollar the latter
of which is a hip-hop alter-ego of nba
all-star
and space xiaomi legacy cast member
damien lillard
fans of the original space jam
anticipating a trailer for the
long-awaited much-delayed sequel
almost got to see a teaser for the movie
way back in july 2018.
just after the end of the nba season the
hottest story in basketball was
where will lebron james play in
2018-2019
according to brandon robinson of
basketball society james planned to
announce his new team
via the then new instagram tv video
platform then
almost immediately after james would use
the service to drop a trailer of some
kind
for the still untitled space jam 2. king
james did go ahead and disclose his
movie to the los angeles lakers
but no trailer emerged instead rumors
have since swelled that the secret
teaser existed
but was held back at the last minute and
will likely never see the light of day
what happened basketball society
reported that james and his management
decided against posting the teaser
because of that premature leak of the
news
a source who worked on the movie told
robinson that the trailer ended with
james wearing a lakers uniform
basically making the teaser an
announcement of his move to la
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one